good morning
like so many of you i have closely
watched the events in minnesota
although the state's prosecution was
successful
i know that nothing can void the loved
ones of george floyd have felt since his
death
my heart goes out to them and to all
those
who have experienced similar loss
i know such wounds have deep roots
and that too many communities have
experienced those wounds
firsthand yesterday's verdict in the
state
criminal trial does not address
potentially
systemic policing issues in minneapolis
today i am announcing that the
police department engages in a pattern
or practice
of unconstitutional or unlawful policing
this effort will be staffed by
experienced attorneys and their
personnel from the justice department's
civil rights division
and the u.s attorney's office for the
district of minnesota
the new civil investigation is separate
from
and independent of the federal criminal
investigation
into the death of george floyd that the
justice department has previously
announced
congress gave the department the
authority to conduct
civil practice pattern or practice
investigations
which look beyond individual incidents
to assess systemic failures
those investigations allow the
department to determine whether a police
department
has a pattern or practice of
unconstitutional
or unlawful policing the investigation
i am announcing today will assess
whether the minneapolis police
department
engages in a pattern or practice of
using excessive force
including during protests the
investigation will also assess
whether the mpd engages in
discriminatory conduct
and whether it's treatment of those with
behavioral health disabilities
is unlawful it will include a
comprehensive review
of the minneapolis police department's
policies
training supervision and use of force
investigations
it will assess the effectiveness of the
mpd's current
systems of accountability and whether
other mechanisms are needed
to ensure constitutional and lawful
policing
broad participation in this
investigation
from the community and from law
enforcement will be vital to its success
the justice department has already begun
to reach out to community groups and
members of the public to learn about
their experiences with the mpd
we also seek to hear from the
department's officers
about the training and support they
receive
because their perspective is essential
all these voices will help provide
investigators the information they need
to conduct a comprehensive assessment
all these voices will be critical to the
reform efforts that will follow
if the game determines the existence
constitutional
or statutory violations
if the justice department concludes that
there is reasonable cause to believe
there is a pattern of practice
of unconstitutional or unlawful policing
we will issue a public report of our
conclusions the justice department
also has the authority to bring a civil
lawsuit
asking a federal court to provide
injunctive relief that orders the mpd
to change its policies and practices to
avoid
further violations usually when the
justice department finds unlawful
practices or patterns or practices the
local police department enters into a
settlement agreement
or a consent decree to ensure that
prompt and effective action is taken
to align policing practices with the law
most of our nation's law enforcement
officers do their difficult jobs
honorably and lawfully
i strongly believe that good officers do
not want to work in systems
that allow bad practices good officers
welcome accountability because
accountability is an
essential part of building trust with
the community
and public safety requires public trust
i have been involved in the legal system
in one way or another
for most of my adult life i know
that justice is sometimes slow sometimes
elusive
and sometimes never comes the department
of justice will be
unwavering in its pursuit of equal
justice
under law
the challenges we face are deeply woven
into our history
they did not arise today
or last year building trust between
community and law enforcement will take
time
and effort by all of us
but we undertake this task with
determination
and urgency knowing that change
cannot wait thank you
you